[Applause]
okay here we are back on overtime and
here are the questions from the
Internet's black knight asks Ross what
do you think of the Catholic Bishops in
America saying that the Republican
budget failed to meet moral criteria ooh
caught you with Todd Todd me caught me
sure this is I think this is a good
example of you know the title of my book
is Bad Religion right and the goal of
good religion is a religion that
challenges I mean with politics that
challenges people on both sides of the
partisan aisle so if you read the New
Testament sometimes Jesus is saying
things that would make liberals
uncomfortable and sometimes he's saying
things that would make conservatives
uncomfortable and I'm good religion bad
religion and on that your book beautiful
book and on no and on the college's book
pity the billionaire there it is and in
your book rush look at that you have the
book rush what you need why you need and
love the rat race but my book nowhere I
own my own so whether Jesus had a lot to
say about were you Donner did are you
yeah it's good all right
when for you why do you feel the lack of
respect for the environment it comes
from lack of education or people just
not caring I think it's the NIMBY where
if it's not in your backyard they're not
gonna do anything about but it is in
their backyard but they don't think it's
in their backyard and they don't want to
know what's in their backyard how close
does it have to come I mean you said I
mean you had 12 of these just smell it
taste it and and then you know it's in
your backyard
well if you smell it certainly you're
not gonna taste it well you are tasting
it if you smell it really you have him
up thank you sitting here I was like
remember the old Cheech and Chong
routine where he steps in the [ __ ] and
never minded the punchline is good thing
we didn't need it you know okay why is
the legalization of recreational drug
such a third rail in American politics
well that's a certainly a good question
I don't know I mean again for 20 such a
disappointment with this president said
and I thought he was like sort of
sending out a signal about the second
term in a little read between the lines
poke signals yes good from the White
House I think that elephant acts I mean
eating right right that means I think
I'm sitting in this chair you are you're
sitting in this big light up chair I
think it may be changing I mean pat
robertson you know who robertson is to
the left of Obama mine isn't that
amazing orally I mean you know and now
and now economists say but to get you
know now economists will say that that's
the way to do it
legalizing pot might raise 14 billion
dollars and by the way three quarters of
that comes from sales of Doritos and the
taxes on the sand raise money bill
there's all sorts of issues like this
right NAFTA NAFTA is profoundly
unpopular nobody will ever challenge it
Obama promised to repeal the Patriot Act
what happened with the bontona Moe is
still open for God's sakes if I were a
little I'd be crazed about that I am
what legalization drugs do i I'm true
I'm getting pretty sympathetic to it so
the party goes afterwards but um pretty
simple I think like I'd like your
position is evolve it yeah like his on
day it's it's evolving it's well my it
is because look at how are you we're
throwing we're throwing
[Applause]
spending precious law-enforcement
dollars sending hundreds of thousands of
people in prison right you know the
damage we know that cigarettes do the
damage we know that alcohol does and to
worry have this country worried about
marijuana
that just seems terribly misplaced all
right it'll make people it may end up
making people's dopey ER but that's
alright we got Jersey Shore and MTV and
all sorts of things good for busy so the
amazing thing is that we're not only
learning the lessons of the Great
Depression again but we're learning the
lessons of prohibition all over again
the 1920s endless rookie accept it when
FDR came into office that was right one
of the first things he did was write rid
of prohibition that's right well yeah I
mean Obama R is he
no no that's unfortunate and and his
statement as I was saying you know it's
the beginning of it was I can understand
people's frustration we can have a
conversation we should about what and
then at the end but we're not gonna do
that but there's kind of there might be
a lesson if we did the right thing
surges if he did the right thing and
that lost the election for him would
still have been the right and I
understand that I do understand but but
after a while don't don't you liberals
get disgusted with the gay right why
can't he be in favor of gay marriage why
legalization of marijuana closing
Guantanamo it's inexcusable this guy
doesn't have the courage of what
everyone presumes to be his convictions
you assume he believes in these things
but he just won't fight and what's
hilarious is they're gonna toss him out
as a socialist right they're gonna throw
him out as a red what were you gonna say
no oh I was gonna say you know in with
some of this stuff though you're talking
about the difference between FBR and
Obama there is again some lessons for
liberals here which is that one of the
reasons that FDR found it easy to sort
of move swiftly and do things quickly
was that government was a lot smaller
than and a lot less unwieldy and there
is a sort of policies in motion tend to
stay in motion phenomenon where you know
a big government while liberals may like
it better it's also harder to change in
a way I don't think that's why FDR found
it easier to move more swiftly he found
it easier to move more swiftly because
the
this was much more profound if
unemployment were 25% in America you can
bet there would be a lot more popular
this is right this is my specialty the
comparison between FDR and Obama and
Obama talks audacity but Franklin
Roosevelt I mean this is this is the man
that he just did whatever whatever he
wanted whatever his advisors dreamed up
there was also incredible creativity you
look at the people that were advising
him back in the 1930s they tossed
orthodoxy overboard and just completely
started over Obama and company are still
listening to the same bunch of like DLC
you know Democratic Leadership Council
for those of you who aren't from from DC
I guess nobody is but the same you know
it's it's the same [ __ ] that is that
has run the Democrats into the ground
again and again and again there's
absolutely no creativity they never want
to try anything new you know it's always
do what Clinton did do what Clinton did
move to the center reach out for the you
know the big compromise was it was his
word the grand bargain he can have a
grand bargain with the Republicans right
and I agree with all that the bar this
president does not have the courage of
Lyndon Johnson
we don't think of Lyndon Johnson as this
sterling individual character but when
it comes to political courage Lyndon
Johnson Trump's Barack Obama we don't
remember Obama had the opportunity that
Roosevelt did the world was at his feet
all that I was in I know all that is
true but it's also true that Lyndon
Johnson and everybody else never dealt
with a Republican Party like this Lyndon
Johnson Oh Lyndon Johnson now wait a
second
Lyndon Johnson as we all know was in a
very different era where there are many
moderates in the Republican Party had
the Southern Democrats to fight which
were more formidable than the
Republicans today okay can I just do one
thing I wanted to ask cuz I thought your
interview with Lynn was terrific and you
called her a hero and I think she is I
would be so interested in your
perspective Lynn on the political race
right now on the political race yeah I
would I was interested in in about
farming pot I think manure could solve
the problem I thought right we got that
I think that um a lot of what I see from
the farming community is the fact that
Obama is a very good person I met him in
person and he's very down-to-earth and
that he could do the right job if he
knew what was really going on and I
think the inform information is
receiving isn't what's really happening
but if you could grow marijuana legally
because I know farmers doing that that's
like a bigger cash crop than anything
they grew yeah they would they thrown it
in our area but usually they end up in
jail really because they find it did you
dip your cord would you would it be a
good crop for you know you are on
national television
I know I understand Bill were you aware
that Obama had a I think a 100% rating
from the American Farmers Union going
into the 2008 election and McCain had a
really lousy rating but if the farmers
of america had decided the election
which guy would have won mccain by this
massive lands right even though he was
crap on the carnation what is the matter
with hands now yeah mister why does it
matter with kids all right thank you
everybody we got a pack up here thank
you
Real Time with Bill Maher's
ask bill and its guests your questions
right after the show at HBO calm